[Music]
even the ancient egyptians knew the
importance of the perfect brow
they wore them dark arched and elongated
but
they'd shaved them off when their cat
died
as a sign of mourning r.i.p
kitty in ancient greece and rome
the unibrow was the way to go it
symbolized
intelligence and was worn by the most
notoriously
beautiful women fast forward to the 20th
century
and every decade brings us a slight
shift in brow beauty
the 20s brought the first commercially
made makeup products
which allowed women to emulate their
favorite silent movie stars
while the 40s and 50s saw a thicker brow
for a softer look the 70s and 80s saw
big hair big fashion and big natural
brows
and then the 90s and 2000s
brought us back to thinly plucked highly
arched and looking good
today a bold brow is the epitome of
fashion but don't worry because if
history tells us anything
the story of the eyebrow is ever
changing hmm some familiar faces in that
one
okay it's true i was a skinny brow queen
in the 90s and then i rocked
a lot of different looks and thankfully
my brows
have grown back and i can show you all
some amazing tools to perfect
your brow grain okay anastasia beverly
hills has been the brow boss for
years and they recently released a new
app that uses augmented reality and the
golden ratio to find
the perfect brow shape for your face
and the app will also give you a
step-by-step guide
on how to achieve that look this is why
anastasia is the brow goddess
and one of those steps probably involves
a tweezer
okay this one is my suggestion it's my
go-to it's the tweezer man ultra
precision slant and there's something
about this one
nailed it perfect it really
grabs you know when you do that tweezer
thing and you're like i can't get the
hair
it's so frustrating not with this baby
every single time
it is perfection okay so
another tool in my arsenal is the flower
beauty
micro pencil and what i love about
this is it's so tiny and thin
that you can really use it in like a
precision point way you can get in those
little tiny holes um
this is definitely a go-to for me
and what i also love about it is that it
has one of those
beautiful little brushes that's like a
pad on the other side so you can really
shape the brow in a different way
another one that i love is our brow fix
now i really love a spoolie
with a really nice amount of product
that you can get
so that you can completely shape the
brow
either very arched and beautiful
or um in fashion
one thing that really never goes out of
style or is always on trend
is that kind of crazy waxy
soapy brow where all the hairs are
dispersed so you can do that really
easily
with this product and that is sort of
the cooler more runway approach
and you can do that with this too so you
can have the jaggedy
more editorial eye or something very
quaffed
and refined with this one product i am
obsessed it is my go-to for brows
depending on what brow i'm looking to
achieve that day
so we bow down to the brows and their
powers to transform
our faces and make sure to show them the
love that they deserve and we'll raise a
brow to
that
[Music]